maybe this is a dumb question i'm not a
guitar player why do you not cut your
strings why do you
always have your strings sticking
straight i always feel like you don't
have an accident yeah that's
right no that's not an accident when i
was in that band the electric sheep i
didn't
cut the strings of my guitar because i
thought it looked cool and i was shamed
by a musician friend and he said cut
your damn strings who do you what do you
think you are you think you're in the
baddest band in town
and i was like i'm definitely not the
best band town so i cut my strings
years later in rage against the machine
i was in the baddest band in town
and so i let my strings go i love that
and like you look at a guy like
billy joe armstrong from green day he
wears his guitar
down almost to his knee yes it looks
very cool
it's super cool to wear your guitar but
you do keep your guitar up high
you're like [ __ ] cool right you don't
care i mean you're most comfortable the
guitar is at exactly the same height
that it is when i'm sitting down and
practicing so it's like it's able to you
know sort of reproduce the exact
circumstances under which i've been
practicing that's what and i
recognize it's not it's not cool but
like i've never that's not
hasn't really been a huge priority is it
important to you what type of guitar you
play is there a certain guitar
that is nothing doesn't matter not at
all and this is controversial in the
world of like sort of guitar players is
that i don't believe it matters at all
and none of the
none of the gear matters whatsoever like
with me i this was probably 1988
i went in i spent a few hours twiddling
some knobs and i just said
i'm done i don't like this sound
particularly it's not what i'm imagining
my head
but i'm sort of obsessing and anxious
about it
i'm gonna never think about these knobs
again i'm never gonna think about this
guitar again
these are the settings i'm now just
gonna worry about being creative
with the sound that i have and those
that amp it's right over there
what is that it's a 50 watt marshall
head and a pv cap which is like what i
bought at the time
and the settings i marked on that day in
1988 the amp is still set to those
settings
the guitar is the one that i've played
on every record and
every show every tour and i just said
i'm no longer
going to burden myself with this i have
to have the right gear and i have to
have the right guitar it's like i got
the guitar i got and now i'm going to
put
all of my energy into sort of
imagination creativity same with
guitar effects i have basically three
there's three pedals
for 35 years that are the same ones that
i've
just applied myself to by embracing
those limitations
helped me tremendously creatively
because i'm never going to worry about
that stuff
at the beginning of rage against the
machine really for me was the turn where
it went from being a
technically skilled musician to becoming
an artist and i found my own voice on
the instrument when i began
self-identifying as the dj in the band
and i stopped practicing scales eight
hours a day
and i started practicing mistakes eight
hours a day
and all of a sudden i was just hearing
the instrument in a different way
and it was creating a vocabulary of
sounds that were
not from the chuck berry book or the
eddie van halen book or whatever
and then and then the blinders were off
tom morello's one man revolution
continues weekly on sirius xm lithium
channel 34.
next tuesday tom is launching tom
morello's radio commandante
radio commandante is on a bunch of
different stations
one week it might be springsteen songs
one week it's on ozzie's boneyard with
my favorite classic medal
one week it's on the coffee house with
my dylan
and woody guthrie jams also next tuesday
tom is launching three new channels
what a show-off tom morello's battle
hymns radio
exposes activism and rebellion through
the music across many eras and genres
tom morello's heavy metal happy hour
radio tom will handpick heavy metal
tomorrow's rifts rhymes and rebellion
radio all from tom morello's personal
record collection
tom has a new podcast tomarillo's
maximum firepower launches next
wednesday
featuring tom's influences as an artist
and an activist
you're going to be busy i think you're
going to have to give up youtube
i've been locked up what are you going
to practice i got between my 97 year old
mom and my 9 11 year old kids like i'm
running a nursing home
and a daycare and a kennel over here so
it's nice to escape up here and
rock some heavy metal jams and talk
about revolution well listen you've made
great music and you're going to make
great radio for siriusxm
the